we love each other in a very friendship
way
there's real love there but i think it i
think in an alternate universe if
ever like we would have i can't even
imagine
but if it if we would have dated i think
it would have
ruined the movie this is going on four
years of working together
and so you don't really get to have a
friendship
with someone if it's sometimes lust gets
in the way and like you know it's
who knows it can get ugly at some point
on a scale of one to ten how much are
you gonna miss me when i'm gone next
year four
a four honey i gotta have my kleenex
handy because i cannot believe we are
saying this are we really saying goodbye
to
all the boys right now i can't believe
it i know
i know well you know what neither can i
i'm like in deep denial
i was such a wreck when we rapped in
korea like
we shot the korean portion of it at the
very end but i was such a wreck
like i truly do not i can't i don't
i think when it's finally out on netflix
it'll like sink in but
i'm not ready wanna i gotta tell you
like i
love the friendship that you and noah
have struck up but i also love how you
created a no
dating pack while you guys were creating
these
films right i feel like it's really easy
and we see this all the time
particularly like young adult
um or and honestly just movies in
general i feel like
a lot of times we always see co-stars
like falling in love with each other
in real life yeah um and
i feel like one
i have been in a relationship um and i
think
all of us at some point have been in a
relationship
and i feel like i feel like it would
have ruined
i i really do i think it i think if
noah and i in an alternate universe
we love each other in a very friendship
way there's real love there but i think
it
i think in an alternate universe if ever
like
we would have i can't even imagine
but if it if we would have dated i think
it would have
ruined the movies i mean i think that
at the end of the day it is a job you
know this is a profession
and it's important to be to have a high
level of professionalism
when going to work um i think beyond
that it was very natural for lana and i
to to just settle into a place of
friendship
we've had each other's back from the
very first day that we met
the first day at work um you know and
the way that our lives timed out that we
were going through very similar things
in relationships in our lives and so
it's just from day one that's how it's
been here's the thing i had to make it
look
like i liked you so somebody else
wouldn't think i liked them like
you watched movies like twilight where
they like the leaves were dating and
then they broke up in the middle of the
film
and i could not even imagine like
working
in a romantic setting with an ex that
sounds
like an actual nightmare i think well i
i i honestly like a it's a literal
miracle that
all of us still feel so much love
towards each other because
you know when you spend that much time
with each other and your whole worlds
are changing together
a lot can happen and i think having that
platonic connection point you know of
always having each other's back
only while having this very organic
natural level of chemistry with each
other has only
helped us you know in the long
term right this is going on four years
of working together
and so you don't really get to have a
friendship
with someone if it's sometimes lust gets
in the way and like you know it's
who knows it can get ugly at some points
unfortunately you might love someone to
death and then suddenly it's like yeah
there's something
or whatever you know right and then you
still have a romantic scene with them
the next day
right right and you hear these stories
and you and so it's you know i just i
think it's
very copacetic it's easier in the long
run and i think you know
it was just very natural to us i see it
my friends it's happened to my friends
they fall in love with their co-stars
and they date and it doesn't work and
it's just like
a nightmare it should be a pact for
everyone just don't do it guys don't go
there
you know but peter does go there with
the grand gestures and everything
lara jean song covey
will you go to prom with me yes
of course i gotta know girl how is your
boyfriend when it comes to the romantic
grand gestures like peter has he taken a
cue from him
has he tried to attempt anything quite
as romantic
you know i think i think
anthony honestly he is so
romantic and he's much better at it than
i am to be completely honest and often
times i'm like
i should learn from lara jean like i can
step up my game a little
but you know i think he i think anthony
um is even more so um
than peter but also anthony's a lot
older
than him so you know he has that age
experience that like
experience yeah let's say look peter set
the bar
pretty high you know when it came to
being
the boyfriend of all boyfriends and by
the way you are still
like the reigning internet boyfriend
just in case you were wondering
but do you feel any pressure in real
life to like live up to anything that
peter aspired to or wanted to do
for lj in the films no not really i mean
i think
i think peter's a really solid target
for for you know how to deal with things
but i don't think he's the by any means
like
the you know quintessential boyfriend
like perfect boyfriend you know i i
think that
he's got a lot of growth to do as well
um you know i think he can be better i
think he's definitely a solid target
and a mile marker for for you know
partners
yeah um but i don't really feel a lot of
pressure i think
i think for me relationships are always
kind of sacred you know you're always
supposed to worship the person one way
or another
um so so no not not really
noah wasn't even there for the last days
that you were shooting but how did the
two of you
you know solidify that last day on set
saying goodbye to each other this
world the life that you've created the
characters
yeah um you know what well when no so
noah wrapped
before me he didn't come to korea with
us um
and that whole entire day i like
was so in denial and i
kind of just avoided him throughout the
day like i didn't want to look at him
like i didn't want to talk to him
because i just like
i was like no this isn't happening and
that was pretty rough like i gotta say i
i as you know we've talked about like i
just feel very grateful um for everyone
on the cast and i feel very grateful
that i got to work with noah because it
really
i think i think our relationship just
really
stood the test of time in these movies
and
i just i really enjoy him as a steve
partner and just as a person so saying
goodbye to him
knowing that we were going to keep going
but that was his last day
really really sucked and then i thought
that of course i was going to see him
you know for press and everything but
now since
you know that the global pandemic um
there isn't really that like closure you
gotta go
you know what i'm looking forward to the
most about college
never having to say
you